well it's a great
to give the first Frankie lecture
lecture in the series of the Frankie
program I guess it's called in science
and humanities and I feel that even
though it was really an accident of
timing but even if the organizers had
had a year to plan it I think they could
not have chosen a better topic to
inaugurate this series than Galileo who
was a true humanist scientist if ever
there was one I read a description of
the pranky program innovation at the
juncture of two interdependent systems
of knowledge that's the Frankie program
and that is go away out to a tea now in
addition to my humanist scientists
subject I want to call attention to the
method that I've used to investigate him
and the method that all that in a way as
part of my topic I could call it the
method of mathematics in history or just
the method of mathematics for short to
put it in slogan form follow the
mathematics the way uh the way an
investigative journalist might say
follow the money
it'll take you to the goods sometimes
following the mathematics actually does
take you to the goods you have to be
able to distinguish among different
kinds of mathematics it can't just all
look alike of course like symbols and
and diagrams otherwise not understood
you have to be able to no good
mathematics from mediocre mathematics or
things that look like mathematics but
aren't mathematics at all or things that
don't look like mathematics but are all
those things can happen but if you are
sensitive to the mathematics of a period
or a culture it can it can be
surprisingly revealing and I want to
give an example that might seem to be
far from my talk in fact I may even seem
to be rambling already but I'm not this
is all all
attending one way the the best example
of this method of mathematics in history
I think was stated most forcibly by
Luciola Rousseau in his book The
Forgotten Revolution which I highly
recommend Rousseau looks at classical
civilization the Greeks and Romans and
that that kind of amalgamated
civilization with with its two classical
languages and they're tightly
intertwined histories a civilization
that even presents itself to us in a
kind of parallel Plutarch's lives you
know are organized in pairs there's a
Greek life and a Roman life as if the
civilization had a kind of built-in
symmetry and as if Greek and Roman were
just two sides of one classical coin
even if you don't agree with that
description it's surely a familiar
picture well now we follow the
mathematics what do you think Greek
mathematics is astonishingly high we if
we still hold it in awe what they did
what about Roman mathematics there isn't
any they they were so in curious about
Greek mathematics that they never even
translated it so right away we see a
brought into a kind of high relief a
contrast that we wouldn't have seen
otherwise just by this method of
mathematics like a like that stain that
a biologist might use to visualize
structure in a self what was what had
been transparent and undifferentiated
suddenly the structure stands out I
don't I I personally can never think of
the Romans in the same way again
well I inadvertently used this method of
mathematics why ago before Rousso book
ever came out in fact in in connection
with a faculty seminar at my college
Mount Holyoke College that was called
mathematics across the curriculum
started in the mathematics department
but we each teamed up with humanists to
create a module for those humanists
courses because we thought there must be
mathematics you know across the
curriculum and and it would never would
never appear in those courses without
some teamwork and my team member was
Angela Mitsuko in the Italian Department
maybe some of you know him great friend
we had so much fun doing this because we
thought there must be mathematics in the
Italian Renaissance and of course we did
find some and we created our module but
it wasn't as easy as I had expected I
thought this would be kind of trivial
mathematics and there'd be nothing to it
but in fact it was completely mystifying
in in many ways there was just something
odd about it that I couldn't put my
finger on
thinking back maybe I could say that
they're sort of frequent recourse to
like magical things and I gradually
realized long after the seminar was over
that the reason for it the oddity of
Renaissance mathematics was that it was
classical mechanics classical called
mathematics sorry that's my physicists
voice classical mechanics is one of our
subjects no I mean classical mathematics
but inherited after a long and complex
history there's the great Greek
mathematics which ought which actually
comes very early and then there was the
long Roman period that was from the
point of view of mathematics the kind of
degeneration Greek mathematics even
didn't keep up the old
standards and the whole subject the
whole subject of mathematics became
overlaid is that the right principle
with philosophical preconceptions that
limited it and and defined it in in
strange ways having probably little to
do with with what it had been originally
for the Greeks and the main the main
characteristic that it took on was a
kind of moral perfection mathematics was
good for you morally it was perfect it
was eternal the way the heavens are
perfect in eternal so among the many
strange things that that are often not
stated explicitly but you gradually
figure out mathematics and astronomy
were basically synonymous and also with
astrology I mean all those words could
be used more or less interchangeably in
the Renaissance a mathematics professor
at a university taught astronomy and
that was because being perfect and
eternal mathematics only dealt with
perfect and eternal things and so it was
just common sense so much so that you
wouldn't even say it that mathematics
couldn't describe things on earth
because on earth you know things are
very imperfect and not at all eternal
things on earth decay and die and and
have none of the characteristics of
mathematics are completely incompatible
with mathematics so a mathematical
description of things on earth what we
would now call physics was you just you
couldn't even imagine it I guess I mean
I'm trying to think myself into that
frame of mind but that's what I did for
a year is to try to figure out what how
does this look to them and as I did this
it occurred to me that these texts that
I was looking at were not that far
removed in time from Galileo but
Galileo's mathematics had never given me
that impression
Galileo seems quite sensible nothing
strange about him
so this son this method of mathematics
had really focused my attention on him
what was it about his mathematics that
was the maid that was different and that
made him different and and since the
questions you ask largely determine the
answers you get I should point out that
I'm gonna be describing a pretty
unfamiliar Galileo because it's it's not
usual to ask this question about Galileo
why was his mathematics different I
don't think you've ever thought about
that but this was this was my my way in
to this topic and having focused
attention on on this question I found a
really startling answer that is when you
when you ask what happened with Galileo
and mathematics the answer is something
pretty amazing Galileo's education was
in Latin and literature the humanities
the arts drawing music his father taught
him the lute probably was a well thought
of musician's philosophy eventually he
was sent to study medicine at the
University of Pisa and it was only there
that he ran into mathematics apparently
this seems almost impossible but there
there's more than one source and they
all seem to agree he discovered
mathematics at a rather at late stage in
his education and became totally smitten
with it and dropped out at the
university to read Euclid and Archimedes
on his own not a very good strategy
professionally
perhaps that was in about 15 85 on his
own in 1589 he was appointed professor
of mathematics at Pisa the very
University that he dropped out of so
what happened those four years must be
pretty interesting don't you think
something pretty amazing happened and
although there's not that much
documentation we don't really know where
he was necessarily for most of that time
probably at home we don't necessarily
need it because we know what he was
doing he was reading Euclid he was
reading Archimedes we have those texts
we may have read them ourselves
he was integrating it all with with his
previous education the arts the
humanities and we can know much of what
he knew about that too so we can sort of
put it together I think and by the way
there is some documentation two amazing
things there are descriptions of two
mathematical experiments that he did in
this short period why experiments
because he was applying his new
mathematical understanding to what he
knew before the in particular two
stories in particular to a very famous
story from Vitruvius whose books on
architecture were the best documentation
of Roman building practices and
aesthetics he you really constituted you
might say a story from Vitruvius and
this is a story that you know even if
you've never read the trivia and I
should almost apologize for what I'm
about to do ready
this is the story of Archimedes in the
crown how Archimedes detected the
forgery of the gold crown now for anyone
who was thinking about Renaissance art
communion this is advertising copy from
the American magazine in the nineteen
forties and as I said I should apologize
I was hoping I would get a little more
of a laugh
the method of the Vitruvius story is
indicated there you you dunk the crown
in just the way Archimedes has dunked
himself into the bath and you collect
the water and somehow that how much
water tells you what you need to know
now this I partly I couldn't resist this
picture but partly I think it also
captures Galileo's own reaction to the
story he thought this was pretty silly
and that that Archimedes could not have
looked like that and done that that was
not at all what Archimedes that divine
man would have done what he would have
done Galileo reconstructed out of two
treatises of Archimedes and then
described in a little pamphlet that he
never published and here it is redrawn
in a 1961 version I don't know how much
detail I should go into here but Galileo
saw this as a as a much much more like
Archimedes himself enough to mention
much clever the idea is you have some
sample and you want to know its density
in modern terms you want to know its
density so you balance it with the
counterbalance here maybe I could use
the mouse now you bring up the water
oh no there is no mouse now you bring up
the water and the sample because of
buoyancy loses weight that's how he
would have said it so it no longer
balances and you have to move the
counterweight in a bit and how far you
move it in represents visually the
density that is how much weight was lost
shows up as how much distance you move
so it's a little scientific instrument
and and it's independent of how big the
sample is it only depends on what kind
of material it is so you could do gold
for example and find that you had to
move it to e or you could do silver and
find you had to move it to F and now you
do the crown and you see that you have
to move it somewhere in the middle
aha
that's how he would have discovered that
the crown was actually an alloy and was
not pure gold behind that reasoning is
one of the two treatises is Archimedes
famous law of the lever which discovers
a law of proportion in nature that the
the weights capital A and capital B
there are in the same proportion as the
lengths of the arms that balance this is
of a mysterious and wonderful
proportionality in nature proof very
beautifully by Archimedes and of course
used in that little apparatus this idea
of proportions in nature stayed with
Galileo all through his life that's
that's really going to be my theme and
we see it right away and it's the first
experiment so to speak which I hasten to
remind you was not a physics experiment
it was an experiment into literature it
was trying to understand that story and
that's someone who was very excited
about mathematics where would they turn
to see mathematics in use now
Renaissance mathematics was not in use
it well in astronomy it was in use but
anyplace else
only a few stories that's where it was
and that's where he went no here's
another story the story of Pythagoras
and the discovery of proportions again
so same same mathematics abstractly
speaking proportions in music this is
from a book that was undoubtedly in the
Galilei household because Galileo's
father was a music theorist who wrote
extensively on on these very things just
to say a little bit about what this is
the book itself is saw is far predates
yellow leo but but this idea was was
completely familiar to people at his
time too
in the upper left there those little men
with the hammers are from the story of
Pythagoras and the Smithee
you know Pythagoras walked by a smithy
and he heard the hammers and he heard
consonant intervals like the fifth and
the octave and he rushed in and and
weighed the Hammers had found that when
they sounded the octave they were two to
one and so forth and he went home and in
did this experiment he hung weights on
strings and and again in every one of
these you'll see that people are are
sounding the sixteen in the eighth which
are in the ratio two to one they're
sounding the octave here this sort of
dulcimer instrument is being played on
16 and eight and similarly for the
flutes and all that well that now that I
think of it there's an experiment we
could actually do ourselves see these
glasses here the sixteen and the eight
we could just do it and I even have some
glasses there and and I'll I'll do this
without spilling on the computer Erik's
computer there's sixteen there's eight
of course it only has to be two to one
that's the point of sixteen and eight
yeah
so that is the two-two-one and so that
should be the octave so let's just hear
the octave it's not just not that had
been music dogma for centuries I think I
have to do something with this but it
was wrong and that is something that
Galileo and his father found by
experiment in the same little period
1785 to 1789 it was published by his
father in 1789 so it's definitely right
in there and what they found was not
exactly that this idea was wrong but
rather that it was moral you don't with
these flutes it's actually right a flute
that's twice as long it's an octave
lower
but these weights that's wrong if you
double the weights you get something
sort of like the glasses there you get a
different interval but if you quadruple
the weight if this is I guess would have
to be 32 and 8 4 2 1 not 2 2 1 then it's
an octave so there is a proportion in
nature a mysterious 1 most mysterious
but it's not the one that that had been
so carelessly accepted for centuries
that must have impressed
Galileo no end the discovery of a
mysterious proportion in nature
following a story once again the story
of Pythagoras it's too bad that there's
no explicit discussion of that in
anything that remained of his reaction
to that but I think that must have been
just so exciting this oh and so here I
just put in words what I have already
said that 4 to 1 makes the octave in
here this is just a point out that some
some proportions are easy to see like
the lutes other lose the frets volute
are placed so that you get the
proportions that you want for this pitch
in that pitch the pegs of course changed
the tension and you can't really see
what the tension is the way you can see
these and that's that's where the
surprise had come well another very
peculiar use of mathematics in
literature and this predates Galileo so
he wasn't the only person doing this
that is following the mathematics but
following it we're following it into the
humanities into Dante's poem in this
case there was a an old tradition about
a hundred years old by the time Galileo
came into this story into the picture an
old tradition in Florence of using
mathematics to discuss and comment upon
the Divine Comedy and I only mentioned
Botticelli here because he collaborated
closely with Christopher Olin Dino at
about this time in in a very sumptuous
edition which is the first example of
this mathematical commentary and Galileo
was and this was undoubtedly part of
what led up to his appointment as
professor was invited to give two
lectures to the Florentine Academy on on
a kind of mathematize ation of that
picture that I just showed you and and
it's very precise and and here I've
drawn it carefully according to the way
Galileo describes it but but he ascribes
it to Manetti
this is and miletti was an architect of
the fifteenth century and the biographer
of Filippo Brunelleschi you know well
loved citizen of Florence
Galileo was asked to to describe this to
his audience not so much
to lay this all out although that's what
he seems to be doing and that that by
itself doesn't seem very exciting
but there was a a strong political
dimension to this which I'm not even
going to go into this this model had
been attacked by Alessandro Vitello of
Lucca who ridiculed this picture this is
not what not AIT's infantile it's like
and he had his own picture and so
Galileo ridiculed him right back and
that was that was the real excitement of
those lectures but but in the course of
it he made a a peculiar statement that
I'm sure this is a little bit
controversial but this is my I'm sure
the later came to worry him no and the
question had arisen whether the roof of
this structure would collapse the roof
being being this part up here which I
didn't really show is solid but that's
the solid roof I should have called
attention to it in the in the Botticelli
diagram tor is a nice grassy crust on
the surface of the earth you might worry
that that that could fall in what do you
think anyway I got Leo argued that no
that was quite strong enough to hold
itself up because we know other domes
which are very similar dimensions like
Florence's own Cathedral dome that
doesn't collapse now you notice that in
in making that argument he's assuming a
kind of theory of proportions of things
if you keep the proportions the same it
will be the same that's not actually
true when they that this dome was
buildable it was almost a miracle if it
had been designed much larger it
wouldn't have been because things
actually get weaker if you simply scale
them up keeping all the proportions the
same that was something that I have
argued I won't go into any more detail
about it than this the Galileo
soon after his talk which in the context
of this of the political meaning of the
infernal lectures really put him in a
tight spot it turned out it never never
act his fears never were realized though
although he never stopped thinking about
it you'll you'll see my evidence for
that well he became professor as I said
perhaps in connection with these
infernal lectures and he spent the next
many years developing an instrument that
had many uses he called it the geometric
and military compass but it was among
other things a computational device
first computing proportions were solving
the rule of three which was the main
problem of renaissance applied
mathematics given three things what's
the fourth one that will make the
proportions the same and here's how you
do it with the the military compass
suppose I've given the problem up there
so how do you do it you open it up using
some ruler or other and measure 138
between the 400s here so 138 is this
side 400 is this side now you just see
how far is it between the 190s
because you have two similar triangles
this is two that as this is two that
because those triangles are similar in
that solves the problem in a sort of
analog way and so the same the same
mathematics that I claimed he had used
right from the start as he began to
develop his mathematical ideas in new
ways the the geometric compass was also
a sighting device it's sort of indicated
here you could hang a little pendulum
and and read off an angle and that would
tell you the angle that you were looking
up and so by various clever uses of
similar triangles again that just means
proportions things in the same
proportion
yes but this is too bad as this is -
well you got the idea you could use this
to do things that that were part of
surveying and practical it was called
practical geometry and and this is not a
particularly sophisticated example of it
the theory of sight lines that's being
used here is of course the same one that
was used in a much more sophisticated
way in the constructions of linear
perspective of painters and Galileo was
considered an expert in that by his
artists friends and and also by his by
his patron Guido Baldo Delmonte who
consulted him on his own texts on the
perspective construction anyway my my
point is just how many different ways we
see the same mathematics appearing and
in appearing in ways that are
increasingly physical we might say and
are getting moving away from the
literary where it started well I've made
myself a little memo down here just just
to remind you Galileo had been an
astronomer at this point for well over
ten years as soon as he was professor of
mathematics he was an astronomer as I
said but he never showed any interest in
astronomy whatever for example in this
uh he wrote a manual for using this
device but he never mentioned sighting
on any celestial object I can augment
that point there's a very wonderful
story from about the same time which
I've which I'm saving depending on time
but let me just say it again he was an
astronomer officially but that's not at
all what he was doing and so once again
just just to reiterate the way I'm
looking at him show us him quite
different from the way from
popular image of him and I truly think
that he was only interested in astronomy
to the extent that he had to teach it
which Ricci did have to do but that in
fact he was doing other things he was
doing this he was using but finding
proportions in nature
well with the with his telescopic
discoveries just a little later in 1610
and the Copernican controversy and so on
we enter the the familiar story of
Galileo which I'm simply going to skip
over because I really think that that
was a bit of an interruption in his
career he had he had a hard time letting
go of things so he persisted in in
directions that maybe were ultimately
counterproductive I think that one was
because and by the way it has nothing to
do with mathematics his work on
Copernicanism there's no there's no
mathematics in it whereas he really was
passionate about mathematics so that's
another that's another rationalization I
give for simply skipping this well-known
chapter and moving on to what came after
and the most important thing that came
after was once again an application of
the idea of proportion in nature now
with no literary precedent to point to
this this diagram is supposed to show
his final version of the law of fall
which he understood this way as
something Falls it's velocity increases
in proportion to the time so that's what
we have here a B that represents the
time of fall EB that represents the
velocity that was picked up and then if
you just draw parallels you have a lot
of similar triangles so so every look at
this triangle don't be distracted by the
rectangle just the triangle all these
lines represent the velocities at
different times so short time a little
velocity has been picked up later time
more of a line
the final time lots of velocity
it's just similar triangles it's just
proportions in nature it's actually a
graph now nowadays we do this without
even thinking it's a graph of V versus T
a physicist would say but Galileo had to
explain what these lines were over here
is the distance that fell but as you see
that has no no obvious relation to
anything else at the same time he had
not forgotten about those old problems
and they're still there they're still in
the same book two new Sciences here's
one talking about the octave again see
the octave here two to one it's trying
to think why is two to one the octave
because of course he and his father had
had revealed that it wasn't that
unambiguous maybe it was four to one if
you look at the weights or two to one if
you look at the links and so on so this
was an argument that it really is two to
one based on how long it takes an
impulse is this pretty much what we what
we would say in a modern physics class
how how long does it take to for an
impulse to go down here and bounce back
and how long does it take this well it
takes twice as long for this one on that
one and so the frequencies are in the
ratio two to one and that's the octave
and so on anyway
still still concerned about that that's
that's my point with this here he is
finally coming clean about scaling and
strength this is this is the the
argument why minetti's inferno actually
would collapse I think he was never able
to say it in public and doesn't say here
either he makes no reference whatever to
to the inferno lectures where he first
encountered this problem rather he just
argues geometrically that this beam here
which has taken rectangular so that it's
easy to talk about its dimensions in its
area and things like that this beam and
that's weight if they were scaled up
enough eventually it would break so
making the ah
exactly the opposite point that he made
in in the Inferno lectures that under
under scaling things actually become
weaker and once again using arguments of
proportion well now in nature I think
this one actually did come from from an
excursion into the humanities it came
from the inferno lectures and and a
description of Dante but but he doesn't
say that because by this time he's
become independent of his original
sources you might say his original
sources in the humanities are no longer
no longer necessary for for the
independent investigations he's making
now someone might say I don't I don't
know if anyone would make this objection
but this is all after the trial and
after he's under house arrest and camps
it can't possibly publish about
Copernicus anymore wasn't his real
passion Copernicus and maybe he was just
doing this because that was all that was
left to him no I do not think so and as
evidence I sorry I've just to say in yet
one more way how absorb he was in the
notion of proportion in nature the law
of fall involves proportions but
proportions of dissimilar things
velocities on the one hand and times on
the other what it means for two
dissimilar quantities to be in the same
proportion is a little bit tricky we
don't we no longer worry about that we
have ways that completely sweep it under
the rug but in Galileo's day this was
not at all obvious and Euclid actually
had given a very sophisticated
definition of what it meant for two
proportions to be equal and Galileo's
last dialogues are about that well and
and another one that uses the balance
back to the balance now he's thinking of
using it to measure the force of falling
water
I'm not quite sure where that problem
came from not not from literature though
no longer from literature well but as I
was saying it wasn't just at the very
end of his life that he was doing this
here 16:27 right when he was writing
that great book the one that I turn
turned me to to a lifelong fan of
Galileo when I picked it up in the
Stanford bookstore the one that got him
into so much trouble and that took him
to Rome for trial he was writing that
book right in this period 1627 but from
that period oh and this is by the way is
from a year when when he was not
actually working on it very hard and all
his friends knew that and they kept
writing letters trying to speed him up
or let him let them see some of it or
things like that right in this period we
get a very curious oration in praise of
mathematics that's what the latin title
is there by Galileo's closest disciple
Niccolo a giunti who was really like a
son to him they're their letters well
adjunctive letters because that's all we
have we don't we just have one side but
a genteel others are charming and funny
and affectionate and and you can tell
that they are perfectly in tune and
Galileo made him professor of
mathematics at Pisa his old job is his
old first position and in in that
position a jaunty gave this inaugural
lecture in praise of mathematics doesn't
that intrigue you doesn't it sound as if
that would be pretty important in
understanding what Galileo thought about
mathematics for very odd reasons this
book was not included in the collected
works by Galileo's great editor Antonio
Favaro
there are 20 volumes of which this would
have been a very tiny piece but Favaro
left it
why I think because it just didn't sound
like a layout to him he comes inside it
in one place in a little biographical
sketch of a gym team saying well the
best that can be said of it is that
Galileo thought it worthy to send to
Kepler what you might say sent to Kepler
he hadn't correspond it with Kepler in
17 years and he'd sent him this thing
doesn't that make it sound pretty
important but but it was left out of the
collected works and as a result no one
has ever commented on it beyond that as
far as I can tell and I've looked as
carefully as I can
well so what is the serration it should
be about astronomy it's a new professor
of mathematics after all that means
astronomy
it doesn't even mention the sternum you
were hardly hardly mentions astronomy is
all about the mathematics of things on
earth so I think even even when Galileo
was most absorbed with the Copernican
problem he he was still just as involved
with what seems to me the real
trajectory of his career and I've argued
that that a lot of this was actually
written by Galileo he frequently
published things over his student names
that that we know he wrote and so I
think this is not not only should this
be in the Galileo opera it because it's
relevant I think it's actually by him to
a large extent just a contra a
controversial point of course well okay
so I've sketched for you a Galileo who
is not the usual one one who actually
drew upon his education in the
humanities in the arts and really what
else could he have done as he discovered
mathematics and in following the
mathematics into these areas
gradually developed methods that were
independent of his literary sources it
it it makes me think that so one could
really with with considerable historical
justification regard physics as a kind
of child of the humanities and the arts
if this is really where it came from now
of course that's not the way we
conceptualize physics but maybe we could
and wouldn't it make a difference that
is we might think of scientists as being
a lot like artists just in this in this
medium they work with tricky materials
they hone their skills they aim to
create effects that will astonish and
please other people according to
rigorous criteria of excellence that how
is that not like an artist I just throw
that out as as a possible direction that
that this line of thought could take us
I don't I don't mean to come to any
grand conclusion just to suggest a way
and since this is only the first lecture
in a series that will be long and
productive I know maybe I could stop
here